if you're a boomer it's real easy to be
a boomer and have access to wealth on
average Boomers have more access than
genen Z does for obvious reasons you're
older you've got a savings you got a
retirement or something so you're likely
living in a house or an apartment or
condo or something like that jenzi is
trying to move into places and they're
running up against the wall they can't
afford it at the same time they can't
afford it guess what's happening in New
York City illegal immigrants are being
given hotel rooms they're giving they're
given free money free places to stay now
Imagine This
imagine you're 22 24 hey you are 24
you're fresh out of college you got a
degree like they told you to get you
can't find a job and you're standing
outside in W with your little you know
atache case holding your resumés and
there's an illegal immigrant buying free
food and going into their hotel room
with a bed a TV a bathroom and security
private security and you're like maybe
if I'm lucky I can get one of those shoe
box pods to live in